[Música]
finalmente el presidente de mexico el de
brasil y el de rusia han felicitado a
yubá idem después de que el colegio
electoral certificará su victoria en las
presidenciales estadounidenses incluso
el líder de la mayoría republicana en el
senado ya reconoció al demócrata
alejándose de la lucha de donald trump
en los tribunales por revertir el
resultado electoral
la agencia europea del medicamento de
estudiará el lunes aprobar la vacuna y
ser valiente contra el commit 19 lo que
permitiría a los países del bloque
comenzar las vacunaciones este mismo año
según dijo la presidenta de la comisión
europea
la reina letizia de españa prometió 120
toneladas de alimentos y artículos de
primera necesidad al visitar honduras
donde está ello está dejaron un centenar
de muertos en el norte del país y en el
occidente hondureño una aldea quedó
totalmente sepultada desde ahí tenemos
reportaje con nuestra biblia de especial
una noche en américa latina y a todos
ustedes que nos siguen por france24 soy
alan austria bienvenidos
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador el de brasil
jair bolsonaro y el de rusia vladimir
putin felicitaron finalmente a yubá y
den después de que el colegio electoral
lo confirmará como presidente electo de
eeuu eran los únicos líderes del g20 que
faltaban por hacerlo tras ser ratificado
baiden emitió su más contundente crítica
donald trump al asegurar que el
mandatario desafió la constitución y la
voluntad popular al no reconocer los
resultados el presidente mexicano
destacó la postura a favor de los
migrantes de joe bites expresó también
mi reconocimiento ante su postura a
favor de los migrantes de méxico y del
mundo
lo cual permitirá continuar con el plan
de promover el desarrollo y el bienestar
de las comunidades del sureste de méxico
y de los países de centroamérica
también el líder de la mayoría
republicana en el senado mitch mcconnell
reconoció por primera vez la victoria
del demócrata en las elecciones
presidenciales alejándose así de las
acusaciones infundadas de fraude
electoral por parte de donald trump y de
su lucha en los tribunales para tratar
de revertir el resultado electoral
y el colegio electoral ha hablado así
que hoy quiero felicitar al presidente
electo joe biden el presidente electo no
es un desconocido para el senado se ha
dedicado al servicio público durante
muchos años también quiero felicitar a
la vicepresidenta electa nuestra colega
de california la senadora harris más
allá de nuestras diferencias todos los
americanos pueden estar orgullosos de
que nuestra nación tenga una
vicepresidenta electa por primera vez
la vacuna fai ser valiente contra el
kobe 19 podría ser aprobada en europa
antes de navidad'
la noticia se produce tras la decisión
del regulador de medicamentos de la
unión europea de adelantar la posible
aprobación al 21 de diciembre la
vacunación en el bloque podría empezar
en torno a la navidad siguiendo los
pasos del reino unido y de eeuu
cada día cuenta trabajamos a toda
velocidad para autorizar las vacunas
kobe 19 que son seguras y efectivas doy
la bienvenida a la agencia europea de
medicamentos a adelantar su reunión para
discutir la vacuna pzifer y bayonne tec
antes de navidad' es probable que los
primeros europeos se vacunen antes de
finales de 2020 méxico reforzará el
control sobre los agentes extranjeros
tales como los de la dea y la cia tras
la aprobación de una polémica reforma a
la ley que regula su actuación estos
cambios que eliminan cualquier inmunidad
en caso de que los agentes foráneos
cometan actos ilícitos en méxico ha
desatado críticas internas y desde eeuu
es vista como una represalia por la
detención un mes atrás del ex secretario
de defensa salvador cienfuegos y unos
temen que dificultará la cooperación
bilateral y beneficiará a las
organizaciones criminales
naciones unidas- reveló hoy cuántas
masacres ha registrado colombia en lo
que va del 2020 y sus estadísticas son
impactantes
las 66 matanzas que reporta casi
duplican
el total del mismo organismo en 2019
registrado en este país y son las cifras
más altas desde 2014 los indígenas
siguen siendo una de las poblaciones más
afectadas informe de maría clara calle
en colombia el 2020 será recordado no
sólo por la pandemia sino también por
ser uno de los años más sangrientos en
el registro el nuevo reporte de la alta
comisionada de la onu para los derechos
humanos mostró que en los últimos meses
ha habido casi el doble de masacres que
el año pasado ya que en 2020 se
registraron 66 matanzas comparadas con
las 36 que confirmó la onu en 2019
además los muertos también se duplicaron
y van a cometer forge pero la alta
comisionada a las naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos michelle bachelet
condena la intensificación de la
violencia que están llevando a cabo los
grupos armados no estatales los grupos
criminales y otros elementos armados en
colombia contra los campesinos indígenas
y afrocolombianos y pidió a las
autoridades estatales tomar acciones
concretas para proteger eficazmente a la
población de population
aunque las estadísticas de la 1 son
escandalosas son aún más conservadoras
que las de la ong colombiana in the path
que sostiene que en el país ha habido 84
masacres incluida la más reciente el
pasado domingo
se confirma la masacre 84 del 2020
comunicado de las autoridades
tradicionales indígenas de colombia
gobierno mayor la comunidad indica que
un grupo ilegal de la guajira asesinó el
líder de la comunidad indígena wayúu
alacat a tres comuneros indígenas y
dejaron varios heridos
en lo que sí coinciden los registros es
en que la violencia se ha enquistado
particularmente contra los indígenas tan
solo la etnia nasa contabiliza a 66
indígenas asesinados en el suroeste del
país de acuerdo con la onu los grupos
armados han matado tantos miembros de
pueblos autóctonos que hace dos meses
los indígenas marcharon de diferentes
regiones de colombia hacia bogotá la
capital para pedir que les respeten la
vida y los territorios el gobierno no se
ha pronunciado sobre el nuevo reporte de
naciones unidas'
a un mes de la devastación por los
fenómenos naturales está ello está la
reina letizia de españa visitó honduras
y ofreció ayuda con 120 toneladas de
alimentos productos de higiene y otros
artículos de primera necesidad además de
24 mil pruebas de detección del hobbit
19 100.000 personas permanecen alojadas
en albergues
nuestra corresponsal kenia torres visitó
una aldea que quedó totalmente destruida
y se encontró con algunos de sus
habitantes bajo esta tierra rojiza
quedaron los recuerdos de una vida de
carlos pérez nacido y criado en lo que
fue hasta hace poco una próspera aldea
cafetalera y agrícola en el occidente de
honduras que tenía 50 años de vivir en
este lugar pero yo nunca creí que me
sucediera lo que me sucede estos días
pero primeramente se viene un deslave
cuando la tormenta se le está verdad a
los ocho días digamos se viene el pelota
fue el que lo vino a destruir la
comunidad y la grossa mente las 500
familias lograron escapar de la muerte
hoy lo esencial es salvar la cosecha de
café y recoger lo que se puede de las
ruinas bajo los escombros también quedó
la escuela donde el maestro selvin
enseño a 160 niños de la aldea estos
niños hoy se encuentran en albergues se
encuentran algunos padres alquilando
algo otros se han ido para lugares lejos
donde los niños prácticamente han
quedado sin nada 289 viviendas quedaron
bajo los escombros después de que éste
cerró prácticamente se partió en dos y
arrasó con todo lo que encontró a su
paso este albergue es el nuevo hogar de
unas 50 familias que viven de las
donaciones y el apoyo de autoridades
locales así transcurren los días con la
esperanza de volver a tener una casa
propia pero gracias a dios que estamos
con vida que lo que le hemos pedido a
dios que nos tiene con salud hasta este
momento pero lo que pedimos por nuestros
hijos un techo una casa que lo más
importante para nosotros el paso de los
huracanes esta y otra en honduras
dejaron un centenar de muertos
perdidas representan cerca del 50 por
ciento del producto interno bruto
el grupo yihadista boko haram anunció
estar detrás del secuestro de cientos de
nigerianos durante el fin de semana más
de 300 estudiantes de la escuela
secundaria científica del gobierno en el
noroeste del país estaban desaparecidos
tras un ataque de hombres armados el
viernes por la noche esto significaría
la ampliación de la esfera de influencia
del grupo yihadista
y finalizamos en eeuu en la capital
fueron tocadas las campanas de la
catedral nacional de washington en
memoria de las víctimas que deja el
coronavirus en el país más golpeado por
la pandemia en el mundo sonaron 300
veces en memoria de las 300.000 personas
que han muerto por el cob y 19 en este
país las campanas sonaron continuamente
durante 30 minutos
[Música]
así llegamos al final de este misión
siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]